jetzt warten einfach meinen kleinen
moment ab ist diese schweinchen schön
gebraten ist dann haben wir alle super
mittagessen ja meine lieben freunde und
damit herzlich willkommen hier zu einer
weiteren mord vorstellung heute am
donnerstag
und zwar von der patsche modifikation
wir wahrscheinlich schon formento
gesehen hat kann man damit tiere
schlachten sie braten ezb da ganz viele
dinge damit machen und ich würde
angefangen direkt erst mal an mit den
kräften rezepten und zwar macht man sich
ein mieter das ist etwas wo man die
sachen dann aufhängt ich zeige euch die
sachen gleich jetzt möchte er erst mal
ganz kurz durch die kräftige sache nicht
dass er zwischendurch mag wie macht man
sich das denn
also hier hat man vier alben singles der
macht man einfach zusammen verkehrt rum
dort nimmt man ja dann hat man hier
einen micky ward einem an ein stick und
vier winning gott dann haben wir hier
eine ist so eine art gefriertruhe
kühltruhe
da braucht man einfach eine just fir als
und vier eisen oder ringsherum dann
haben wir hier ein fiel innerhalb dafür
brauchen wir einen stick und zwei eisen
zu samstag angeordnet dann haben wir
hier drei sixt wie man so diagonal
zueinander passen und man bekommt einen
speed und man bekommt ein speed prob das
ist das was den speed quasi festhält was
im boden steckt und es macht man einfach
so mit einem y aus fix und jetzt würde
ich sagen kommen mal erst mal was macht
die mod denn überhaupt also wir können
jetzt erstmal wir sehen da hinten schon
ein paar schweine mit schafen
funktioniert glaube ich nicht weil wir
jetzt schon schwarz fleisch wir töten
und setzte hier so ein schwein und wenn
wir das schwein töten sehen wir schon im
inventar der bekommen wir nicht okay das
war's doch von vorhin von seiner kleinen
test sache aber normalerweise bekommt
man ja nur normales fleisch bei
schweinen und ich hab ja zum beispiel
auch im bett kick bekommen also sondern
sein sohn jean tote schwein habe ich
jetzt im inventar da kann ich auch hier
nochmal ein bisschen rum gucken habe ich
hier noch irgendwelche anderen teilen
aber ich kam einfach noch ein schwein
töten und dann bekomme ich hier zb
wieder sonntags habe ich schon zwei die
kann man nicht stecken das einzige was
man nicht alles bei kühen
wir können aber hierbei beimischen
gucken nach noch an kombi also in zombie
tötet die skins sachen also zombie kann
töten ein schwein eine scharf eine kuh
und ein schicken weil das das einzige
ist man quasi essen kann weil ich meinen
was es creeper fleisch und wer ist
beispielsweise irgendwie schon
schaafs fleisch was hier gab schon
gesagt habe also ich würde sagen wir
machen das ganze ist man im bett pk das
relativ nah an der nähe war und zwar
jetzt das mit hoch und packen das in
drei blöcken opponenten sind pilze und
packen da hinten auf und packen das in
drei blöcken hitzigrat ganz gut drei
blöcken hin weil wenn ich das zum
beispiel hier in packen würde und ich
werde es versuchen daran aufzuhängen
steht nadine of space trading die hoch
und dann muss man das ein bisschen höher
packen da nehmen wir quasi einfach unser
tepic hängt das ganze daran und jetzt
hängt das hier runter ich weiß das ganze
sieht ein bisschen unmenschlich aus und
so ein bisschen wie beim fleischer aber
so ist das nun mal und zwar wenn ich das
ganze jetzt kaputt schlage seht ihr
passiert ein kleiner fehler als und zwar
sehen wir jetzt hier diese diese hit box
das heißt wir müssen dann quasi einmal
den block kaputt machen und auch einmal
hier drauf schlagen wenn es das ganze
wieder weg und jetzt habe ich mein totes
de verschwendet aber egal wir hätten es
einfach mal wieder hin und zwar wieder
die hoch daran nehmen dass der peak tram
auf hängen und jetzt hängt es da wenn
mich das dann allerdings sehr sehr lange
dort hängen lassen kommt es irgendwann
zu dem fall ist das ganze dann schimmelt
und
irgendwie kaputt geht und keine ahnung
deswegen kann mir das ganze mit einbauen
von allen seiten am besten wirklich so
viel einnehmen wie möglich und dann halt
noch vielleicht irgendwie von hier und
jetzt ist es quasi eingebaut jetzt
bleibt es kühl oder mann packt ein lava
einer darunter aber das möchte jetzt
machen weil ich da nicht so viel platz
und da wird es daraus fließt und soll so
hier dann einfach ein lava einmal hin
packen und dann wäre das ganze auch
quasi warm gehalten also ich weiß nicht
welches produkt man warm behält aber es
soll auch ein bisschen verladung ich
find's ganz kurz nur mit als gehen würde
also mit dem lager ein bisschen unnötig
deswegen schon als wir den dreck wieder
weg details brauchen wir glaube ich auch
nicht mehr
also so kann man das kühl halten das
geht dann halt auch noch mit ganz vielen
anderen mit nämlich der toten co dem
toten schicken und dem toten zombie die
können wir jetzt einfach mal alle
aufhängen so freuen ich hab das ganze
jetzt aufgegangen wir sehen hier den
toten zombie der bewegt sich sogar noch
ein bisschen weiter quasi schon die
ganze zeit und tod tod keine ahnung
dann haben wir halt dieses hühnchen am
rumgammeln und hier die kuh die kultur
in besonders leid weil ich da so
ausgestreckt liegt und ich mag höhe
irgendwie und wir können die sachen
jetzt auch heute also wir denken dann
liebe leute denken sich dann vielleicht
ja was ist da wenig federn will man
bekommt ihr mann jean todt ist schicken
deswegen haben wir ein filet nackter
können wir dann einfach richtig drauf
machen und dann bekomme ich aber die
mädchen beispielsweise jetzt mal eine
feder
hier bekommen wir ein bisschen von dem
ding von der schweiz sondern bekommt ich
da bekommt man gar nichts mehr bekommt
man auch nichts weil das scheinen drt
nur fleisch
oder hammelfleisch die optik also zum
fleisch bringt einmal und beim kombi den
kann man halt nicht heute das geht halt
nicht da bewegte sich dann halt nur ein
bisschen komisch und schneller
und ja das ist halt das so zumal ihm
viel lena es braucht und die teile hier
werden jetzt mit der zeit so ein
bisschen schlecht werden die verändern
sich dann immer so ein bisschen von der
farbe das sehen wir schon die werden so
ein bisschen bisschen ja wir nehmen das
ein bisschen pinker und so weil die halt
nicht mit ice eingebaut sind und er
hierbleibt total frisch das dann erst
mal die sache und wir können dann auch
letztendlich mit diesem mitglieder mit
rechts drauf klicken und dann bekommen
wir hier beispielsweise das fleisch von
dem teil 8 der stahlkocher falscher
stimmt hab ich denn gerade gedacht dass
man in vielen etwas bekommt kann ich
auch richtig drauf machen dann bekommen
wir auf das fleisch
hier können wir das auch machen dann
bekommen wir hier das gleich und hier
können wir das wieder nicht machen weil
das ist ein kombi dann habe ich jetzt
ein paar sachen bekommt man bekommt halt
auch knochen ich habe drei knochen 34
roth schicken und drei rock und vier
robbie falls man bekommt der relativ
viel raus also wenn ihr zum beispiel
mehr fleisch haben wollt dann einfach
dass die kuh ich bin gleichzeitig
mittelfeld camp so einfach die kuh und
so erst mal einen viele hoch aufhängen
bisschen abwarten blabla da bekommt man
ein paar mehr sachen raus allerdings
möchte ich euch noch eine andere sache
zeigt und zwar war das ist erstmal mit
diesen drei teams
allerdings gibt es auch noch etwas
anderes und zwar wir im wissens wieder
also wir fliegen jetzt erst mal wieder
zusammen schwächen hin
so dahin haben wir noch ein paar da
fliegen wollte hitler töten diese
schwein und ihr wisst ja schon dass wir
dann bekommen wir bekommen jetzt ein
jetpack also ein totes schwein und das
aller kurz an dieser modifikation finde
ich ist die tatsache dass wir hier jetzt
beispielsweise auch noch sagen wollte
uns war dieses fleisch was wir gerade
bekommen haben jetzt ist es total
vergessen man man man
wir haben eine eiszeit ist ganz normale
kiste nur also mit dem gleichen klasse
mit einer anderen textur und das ist
halt eine gekühlte test also wenn wir
zum beispiel dieses fleisch was wir da
gerade bekommen haben habe ich euch ja
gesagt dass man da viel mehr bekommt ich
habe zum beispiel bei einer kuh gerade
vier fleisch bekommen
das wird allerdings wenn ihr das im
inventar einfach verhalte das ist ja
quasi denn schlechtes fleisch also dass
abdi quasi von einem tier genommen was
darum hingen nicht mehr gekühlt war und
alles möglich und blabla das wird mit
der zeit zur rotten flesh und umsatz
kühl zu halten müsste das in einer eis
packen und ja dafür halt die heißt es da
so freuen und jetzt haben wir hier
nämlich dieses tote schwein und können
uns jetzt hier einfach ihr seht schon
ich hab mich ein bisschen vorbereitet
wir können jetzt hier einfach mal ein
netter ranking platzieren oder hatte ich
sogar schon direkt vom frühen vom test
jetzt packen wir hier einfach mal feuer
hin packen hier einen spot drop hin mit
shift und 60 hier ein jetzt mit stift
und 60 da eins drauf und jetzt sehen wir
ja schon sonne tode stange jetzt können
wir das schwein einfach mit stiftern
draufpacken können mal eben kurz in den
game mode null gehen stiften und links
klicken das ganze schwein dreht sie
jetzt im kreis und jetzt warten wir
einfach mal ein kleinen moment ab ist
diese schweinchen schön gebraten ist
weil dann haben wir alle super
mittagessen soll sehen wir das schon
jetzt können wir das feuer wieder
ausmachen können mit lieber nehmen
shiften und rechts ich darauf machen und
ihr seht schon jetzt bekommen wir hier
da jetzt willkommen wie beispielsweise
knochen und einen korb also das ist
quasi die funktion von diesem ding hier
wir können das ganze auch noch mit akku
beispielsweise machen da geh ich mir
einfach ganz kurz wieder in den games
denn obst sondern das ganze mal wieder
an also bei mir hat es nie geklappt
als ich mir sachen aus dem game
aufgenommen habe ich musste quasi immer
die teile direkt zu töten
und ja so sieht das ganze quasi bei
einer kuh aus also es sieht sehr ich sag
mal kam aus möchte davon mal einmal so
ein screenshot machen er das recht das
sind echt total
ihr seid ihr live dabei wie ich meine
familie hier mache so makaber ist das so
das sind echt krass aus also bei mir hat
es noch nie geklappt als ich wirklich
teile aus dem game aufgenommen habe ich
jetzt wieder den game auf null drehen
das jetzt hier mal so hat es bei mir
noch nie geklappt ich weiß nicht wollen
dass weg als man muss die teile wo
wirklich getötet haben
und ja ich würde sagen das war's mit der
modifikation wir können auch warten bis
das ganze an brennt das kann man
beispielsweise bei den männchen machen
papier wieder ins bild drauf habe das
feld schicken
packt das einfach mal daran jetzt sehen
wir hier das checken wir gehen wieder in
den gay games 0
ich lass das ganze teil im kreis drehen
obst liegen wieder ein paar sachen und
ihr werdet jeden moment sehen
ihr werdet ihr im moment sehen dass
dieses münchen gleich einfach verbrannt
seien wir dich mal noch mal also manche
sachen brauchen ein bisschen länger
ich würde sagen wir geben dem hühnchen
noch ein bisschen zeit das war sie erst
mal mit der modifikation wir haben hier
quasi einige sachen die hinzugefügt
werden ich gehe mal wieder in den gamer
1 wir haben hier dinge wie
beispielsweise dies mit hochdruck wo man
die teile daran aufhängen kann und ich
kann seine sammlung machen kann alles
mit prob und speed wo man das machen
kann was er hier gerade seht dann haben
wir hier bei michelle wird dieses kind
chicken skin pack also das sind die
teile die man aufhängen kann wenn die
quasi schon gehäutet sind mit dem viele
innerhalb dann haben wir hier
meinem fuß schicken baby von björn borg
also wenn zu lange oben drauf war und
dieses zu rotten flesh wird halt alles
wenn es quasi einfach nur rumhängen
dann haben wir hier die ice schätzt in
der
man dinge aufbewahren kann die dann halt
so kühl gelagert werden jetzt sehen wir
hier zum beispiel ist das ganze jetzt
das heißt wir können jetzt eben perfekt
zum ende des videos macht das mal ganz
kurz nach rechts drauf und ihr seht ich
bekomme knochen und vier bern schicken
und ja es ist nicht so ganz gesund das
zuerst nicht weiß gar nicht was passiert
wenn ich das jetzt setzen würde
aber na ja das kommt ihr ausprobieren
ich würde sagen wenn es euch gefallen
hat diese mod review dann zeigt es mir
mit einem mag ich und schreibt mir bitte
in die kommentare die ich eventuell das
nächste mal vorstellen soll
und ich würde sagen wir sehen uns am
morgen in den morgen video wieder oder
gar nicht mehr ist mir ein ich habe
übrigens wieder meinen konnte daran
nichts